have you ever learned a language even if
you haven't you're probably aware of
words in other languages that are
instantly recognizable in English how
about the word burrito that's a Spanish
word for a delicious food that comes in
a tortilla Which is another Spanish word
that you probably know even if you don't
know Spanish
so it is with botany some of the words
like root will be familiar others like
inflorescent or trichome may be
unfamiliar
but learning some of these unfamiliar
terms will help you enjoy plants more
think of how much richer your life is
because you can order a burrito or a
croissant and have the expectation of
those delicious food items so it is then
you see for an example a miniature Leaf
called a stipule and you recognize it
instantly and that one character helps
you identify an unknown plant
these terms will help you be able to
talk about the parts of plants and make
identifications in the field we'll start
from the ground and work our way up and
then we'll discuss fruit types
typically The Roots aren't used too much
in identifying plants though I do know
that many grasses are indistinguishable
without their roots there are two main
types of root systems plants can either
have a Tap Root which is like a carrot
or a fibrous Roots where no one root is
bigger than the others
some plants can also have adventitious
roots
in biology the word adventitious means
an unusual anatomical position or formed
by accident
in the case of adventitious Roots it
means in an unusual position so that
these are roots that develop along the
stem or even from the leaves
an example of adventitious Roots would
be prop Roots found in corn or stilt
Roots found in mangroves
we'll discuss another important
identifying traits of roots as we meet
them but for now let's know fibrous
roots and tap Roots moving up the stem
there is a bit more variety
some stems are green which means that
those stems are photosynthesizing and
that can be an identifying trait
mostly though when we discuss stems
botanists are really discussing the
overall plant habit which means growth
form don't confuse habit with habitat
The Habit is the overall morphology of
the plant and the habitat is the type of
ecosystem in which the plant grows
when thinking about stems botanists will
first determine if a plant is Woody or
herbaceous sometimes plants might be
Woody at the base so it's important to
check the base when identifying this
character
herbaceous growth forms are grasses and
herbs which are also sometimes called
forbs this word forb comes from the
Greek forebay or fodder from forbane to
feed an herb or a forb is generally any
herbaceous plant that isn't a grass so
even a weed like a dandelion would be
considered a forb but so would useful
fodder like Alfalfa we'll learn to
identify grasses in a later lecture but
for now keep those terms in your mind
for herbaceous plants
Woody plants can include trees shrubs
and sub shrubs which are smaller shrubs
there are a few other words that define
the overall growth and these plants can
have Woody tissue or not
again there are other habit descriptors
but we'll meet them as we meet the
families that they typify
along with the plant's overall habit
many identification books will ask
whether the plant is an annual or a
perennial
annuals usually flower from Spring melt
to First Frost which is more true in the
garden than in the field but this is
still a useful guideline in the field
many annuals will Bloom when there is
adequate water such as many desert
annuals in fact some plants will behave
like annuals in cold climates but will
be perennials in milder climates such as
poppies
perennials will have a shorter flowering
time typically two to three weeks but
they will come back the next year
remember that no plant lives forever and
even perennials will die in the field
anything that is Woody even at the base
is a perennial and herbaceous plants can
be either perennial or annual and you'll
have to use flowering time as a clue
moving up to the leaves this is where a
lot of the identification will take
place for many broad leaves trees the
shape of the leaf and the texture of the
bark are the main identification
characteristics
broad leaves means that the leaves are
Broad and this is usually contrasted
with needle-like such as in conifers
leaves are also classified as evergreen
or deciduous not all conifers are
evergreen remember the larches and not
all broad-leaved trees are deciduous
in the tropics many broad leaf trees are
evergreen
even in North America there are some
broad-leaved evergreen trees especially
in the southern states an example would
be some species of magnolia tree and the
Live Oaks
we won't delve into all the leaf shapes
at this time namely because Leaf shape
is not a particularly strong defining
characteristic for families
Leaf shape is best for defining species
and we'll look at some fam examples in
later families
what is very useful for defining
families is the arrangement of leaves on
the stem
the location where leaves insert into
the stem is called the node
typical leaves have a flat base and a
leaf stem that connects the blade of the
leaf to the main stem this Leaf stem is
called the petiole how the petioles
attach to the stem determines the leaf
arrangement and there are three main
Leaf Arrangements
an opposite leaf arrangement occurs
where one leaf inserts directly opposite
a leaf on the other side of the stem
this is in contrast to an alternate leaf
arrangement where leaves you guessed it
alternate up the stem
one way to learn plants is to memorize
families with particular characteristics
such as all the plant families that have
opposite leaves
however there are a couple hundred plant
families that could have opposite leaves
especially if you live in the tropics
still these are important terms to know
as they can be especially useful for
determining the differences between two
families that have similar looking
flowers
the third type of leaf arrangement is
called world this word sounds a lot like
world and that's probably the it's
derivation the Whirl of a spindle
World means that the leaves are arranged
in a circle around the stem think a
whirl of world leaves
sometimes it's a bit confusing to get
the leaf arrangement right and that's
because what constitutes a leaf can be a
bit tricky in some plants a leaf can be
simple or compound
a simple leaf has only one blade and one
petiole a compound leaf will have more
than one blade and so these numerous
blades are called leaflets
so even though it has lobes the maple
tree is still one blade while the Clover
has three leaflets so it is a compound
leaf
although there may appear to be more
than one petiole there is only one and
in the junction between the petiole and
the main stem can be found the key to
determining if a blade is a leaf or a
leaflet
when you look in the axle which is a
fancy term for the space between where
the petiole inserts and the main stem
there will be a very small Leaf Bud
there if the structure is a true Leaf if
it's a leaflet there will not be one of
these Leaf buds
because the bud is located in the axle
it is called the axillary bud
an anatomy axillary means armpit so this
is sort of like the armpit of the plant
where the stem functions as the body and
the leaf petiole is like an arm
when the leaflets are arranged like a
feather they are called pinnate from the
Latin pinatus meaning feathered
common example here would be the leaves
of an ash tree when the leaflets are
arranged around the central axis like
your fingers around your palm the leaf
is called palmate an example of palmate
leaves would be the horse chestnut
these terms penate and palmate are also
used to describe the leaf venation which
refers to the arrangement of the veins
within the leaves
the veins of the leaves contain the
vascular tissue which is the xylem and
phloem the xylem carries water and
minerals up from the soil and the phloem
carries the sugars produced in the
leaves by photosynthesis to the rest of
the plant
leave the nation can also be linear like
the veins in Blades of grass and this
trait is usually limited to a particular
group of plants called the monocots that
will meet in a future lecture
the last two Leaf traits important for
identification are Leaf margins and leaf
hairs
the margin of the leaf refers to the
outer REM of a leaf and that can be a
defining character if the leaf margin is
smooth as it is in a magnolia then it's
called entire
if it's Jagged in some way like in an
Elm it's given a different name but the
most common of these Leaf margin terms
is serate which does indeed look like a
serrated knife at the edge of the blade
when you look at these Leaf serrations
you might wonder why the leaf would do
that
in a 2016 review article in current
biology by Daniel Chitwood and the Lima
Sinha
it suggests that there's a trend of more
entire leaves being found in the tropics
and in the Arctic the mid-latitudes it
seems have more leaves with dissected or
non-entire margins
while there are several hypotheses for
why this trend might exist there's no
definitive answer yet it could be that
leaf dissection is a good way to let
light down to the lower levels in a
tree's canopy or it could be that leaf
dissection is an easier way to get your
photosynthetic Machinery up and running
during the growing season without
producing an entire Leaf get it entire
leaf
as for our last distinguishing trait for
leaves usually just the presence of leaf
hairs is enough
botanically Leaf hairs are referred to
as trichomes and unlike Leaf margin
shapes the function of trichomes is well
known the hairs on leaves work a lot
like hair on animals the trichomes can
regulate Leaf temperature and also serve
as a glandular outlet for chemicals that
will protect the leaf from herbivory
usually from insects the trichomes can
also help prevent water loss from by
increasing the boundary layer of air
around the leaf
essentially this means that the wind
speed near the leaf will be slower and
this will slow evaporation of water out
of the leaf
lastly trichomes can serve to protect
belief against too much solar radiation
moving up the plant on our terms to know
for plant identification we come to
flowers
though we covered flowers in chapter 3
they are so important for identification
will have a very brief review
recall that flowers are the reproductive
organs of the plant they will also be
the basis for all fruits that the plant
will form
however wherever there is a flower there
isn't a guarantee of a fruit that flower
has to be pollinated that is pollen
which carries the sperm of the plant
must reach the pistol of the plant in
order for fertilization to occur
these two words are not synonymous
pollination means pollen has been
transferred and fertilization means that
the sperm has reached the egg and
fertilized it to form the zygote which
develops into the embryo inside the seed
before we even investigate the structure
of the flower we can observe how the
flowers are arranged on the plant
this Arrangement is called the
inflorescence and the type of
inflorescence can be very important in
determining plant families
there are two main categories of
inflorescences they can be determinate
or indeterminate
a determinate inflorescence is one where
the flower production of that plant is
genetically predetermined to stop at a
certain size
an indeterminate inflorescence is one
where flower production continues
through the growing season of the plant
the main determinate inflorescence types
are all A variation on a sign which is
an inflorescence where the central
flower develops first
in the figure the half moon shapes are
the flowers that are first to open
indeterminate inflorescences are a bit
more varied the first flowers to open
are at the base and as the plant
continues to grow up or out more flowers
develop the most common indeterminate
inflorescence is a Racine like foxglove
or lupine this word comes from the Latin
word racimus which means bunch of grapes
I'm not sure a Racine looks like a bunch
of grapes but there are many flowers and
they alternate up the stem
the flowers will be on a small stalk
called a pedestal and if there is no
pedestal but the flowers on are on
either side of the stem then the
inflorescent is called a spike
if there is more than one flower coming
off of the stalks then the inflorescence
is a compound regime or a panicle and a
good example here is a lilac
if the flower stalks all join to a
central location on the stem to form an
upside down
umbrella shape this inflorescence type
is called an Umble from the Latin
umbbella meaning sun shade or parasol
and lucky for us this is the same root
as umbrella so the humble and
fluorescence should be easy to remember
humble is an upside down umbrella a good
example of an humble is wild carrot
if we continue our discussion of
distinguishing terms we can explore the
flower itself
moving from the bottom to the top of the
flower we begin with the green leaf-like
structures that are just below the
colorful petals these sepals usually
form the outermost part of the flower
bud
the petals are typically colored in
order to attract pollinators which are
animals that will transfer pollen from
one plant to another
if the flowers are showy which means
typically that they're noticeable and
colored then they are usually animal
pollinated
sunflowers by contrast are decidedly not
showy and lack much color and these
flowers tend to be wind pollinated
an example of an animal pollinated
flower is this pretty Scarlet Helia or
ipomopsis aggregata its red color
signifies that it is attracting a
pollinator and the long tube shape of
the flower tells us that it's pollinated
by an animal with a long tongue such as
a butterfly or a hummingbird
an example of a wind pollinated flower
is this paper birch Bachelor pepifera
this flower is inconspicuous and small
the flowers have no bright color or
smell and that's because these flowers
don't need to attract insect pollinators
there are numerous descriptive terms for
the overall shape of the flowers
we'll start with overall flower symmetry
this is an important diagnostic
character and there are three different
symmetry types for flowers
if the flowers can be dissected in
multiple planes like a pizza it has
radial symmetry an example is this
evening primrose
if like a human there's only one way the
flower can be dissected to reveal two
symmetric halves then it has bilateral
symmetry an example is this digitalis
flower
lastly sunflowers have no symmetry like
members of the Cana genus and these are
called asymmetric
like Leaf shape there are many different
names for the shape of the petals
collectively the petals are referred to
as the Corolla and some words used to
describe the Corolla are tubular
trumpet-shaped and funnel shaped each of
these is a variation on the theme
tubular
the trumpet shape flares out at the end
and the funnel shape flares out even
more at the end
rather than Define every floral type
here I'll introduce important floral
shapes as we meet them and most
identification books will have a
glossary While most of these Botanical
terms are Universal it never hurts to
see just what the exact definition is
for the identification book you're using
moving to the inside of the petals we
come to the male parts of the flower or
the stamen they are comprised of the
anther which sits on the filament
usually it's the number of statement
that we're concerned with in
identification so we'll leave it at that
for now
the pistol is the female portion of the
flower it contains the sticky stigma at
the top where the pollen lands and a
long style that goes down to the ovary
where the ovary sits in relation to the
rest of the petals and sepals
collectively called the perianth will be
important
a superior ovary sits on top of the
petals and sepals and an inferior ovary
sits below the petals and sepals
some plants have more than one pistol
determining the number of pistols is
important to distinguishing the fruit
type
fruits that are formed from One pistol
are called Simple fruits this is the
most common fruit type and just a few
examples are apples oranges Tomatoes
cherries and aggregate fruit is one that
is formed by the development of a number
of pistols from the same flower an
example of this type of fruit is a
Blackberry which is an aggregate of many
different fruits
the ovary within the pistol can be
divided into different segments called
carpals if there is just one carpal in
the ovary then the flower is monocarpic
if these carpals aren't fused then the
pistol is the same as the carpal but if
there is more than one carpal and it's
fused into one pistol then the flower is
sin carpus
many times the number of styles or the
number of stigma lobes will be a clue as
to how many carpels are contained in the
ovary
the way that the ovules the unfertilized
eggs inside the carpals are attached to
the carpal wall is also important for
some families now we've used the words
carpal and Pistol and sometimes these
mean the same thing but other times they
don't for example you can have one
flower with three unfused carpels and
three simple pistols but it's also
possible for a flower to have three
fused carpels and also three Styles and
three stigma but since the carpals are
fused there is only one pistol
where the ovules are attached inside the
carpal is called placentation again
placentation becomes more important when
determining species or Genera rather
than families so you needn't commit them
to Memory just be aware of their
existence
as we discussed the ovary is where the
ovule is contained the ovule is the name
for the unfertilized egg when that egg
is fertilized the embryo begins to form
inside the developing seed there may be
more than one ovule in a carpal and more
than one carpal in an ovary
most fruits are simple fruits that is
they are derived from One pistol
keep in mind that the fruit is the
swollen ovary and keying out fruit types
is actually pretty fun
there are many fruit Keys available
online and you can collect fruits from
the grocery but also from the backyard
it's really fun and you get to eat your
study specimen when you're done
so simple fruits derived from One pistol
can be dry at maturity or fleshy
if a fruit is dry at maturity it will be
dehiscent or indehissant that word
dehiscence is derived from the Latin D
hiss which means to split so a dehiscent
fruit is a dry fruit that splits open at
maturity I like to think of it as
dehiscent and the hiss sound might
remind you of the seed splitting out of
the fruit
it may be useful here to think of the
2018 research findings of Dwight
Whitaker at Pomona College who found
that the seeds of the Wild Petunia ruia
cilia tilaflora D hiss out of the fruit
at 15 meters per second and that these
seeds can spin up to 100 000 rotations
per minute which is the fastest seed
travel known
according to the journal Nature that's
the fastest natural projectile known
let's begin with the decent fruit types
remember they hiss or break open at
maturity to release the seeds one of the
most common is the legume and if you're
familiar with the garden term legume
you'll know that this term includes
beans and peas and peanuts which aren't
actually nuts but we'll get into that
the legume fruit is derived from one
carpal and that maturity it will split
along both the top and the bottom
similarly a follicle is a lot like a
legume but it will only split along one
side an example here is the state flower
of Colorado the Columbine
remember we said that the ovary could
contain several carpals or chambers
within the ovary
apsole is derived from several carpals
and there are several variations on this
theme depending on how the capsule
splits
if the capsule splits in the middle of
the locules then is called a locked
usidal capsule and lilies and irises are
good examples if capsule splits along
the walls of the locules which are
called SEPTA then it's called
asepticidal capsule and these capsules
will open at the top the fruits of Yucca
and Agave provide good examples of
septicidal capsules
apixis is a capsule that has
circumcisiled dehiscence
it's along a horizontal line that goes
all the way around the fruit or
circumscribes it hence the name
circumcessile
essentially this is like the lid of the
fruit popping off to release the seeds
purslane is a good example of a plant
with a circumcisile capsule
perhaps the most ornamental of this
group is the poricidal capsule which
will have round holes on the fruit
through which the seeds are released
the most famous example of the poricidal
capsule is the poppy fruit
dry fruits can also be indecent which
means that they will not open when they
mature
you may be wondering how the seeds will
be dispersed remember that the fruit
itself may be dispersed along with the
seeds and that is the case here most of
the indehiscent dry fruits are
one-seeded fruits we'll start with
everyone's favorite the whirly bird
Samara from a maple tree
a samara's defining character is that
part of the fruit wall grows into a wing
that creates the whirly bird kids love
to play with
apparently the wing AIDS in secondary
dispersal that is after the fruit Falls
initially from the tree the wind can
help it ride the wind the second time
away from the parent plant
I think it's good to talk about a
schizocard next because the double
Samara can also be defined as a
schizocarp the prefix schizo means split
and the schizo carp has two equal halves
each called americarp so in a double
Samara common to sugar maple or asyl
Acer sakarum each Samara is americarp so
this fruit is a schizo card
if you've ever eaten a sunflower seed in
the Shell then you've cracked open and a
keen this is a one-seeded indeciscent
fruit where the one seed think of your
sunflower seed is attached to the fruit
wall at a single point
though it's not apparent in the
sunflower seeds in the store many ekenes
will have a protrusion almost like a
beak out of one point of the fruit
remember I said earlier that a peanut is
not a nut because a peanut is a legume
well a coconut is not a nut either and
neither is an almond we'll learn what
those are in a minute in botany a nut is
any indehiscent dry fruit with a single
seed and a hard Smooth Wall
also nuts tend to have caps on them
which are really part of the old flower
that fuses together
this is true of an acorn which is a nut
it's hard walled and has a a cap or a
cup on it
our last indehiscent dry fruit is grain
or a carryopsis which is when the fruit
wall and the seed coat are fused and you
guessed it this is the fruit type for
all the grains such as corn and rice and
wheat
we'll move on now to fleshy fruits where
just like it sounds the fruit wall
becomes soft and fleshy as it matures
a droop is the fruit type for some of
our most beloved fruits droops are one
seeded simple fruits the innermost
portion of the fruit wall which is
called the endocarp becomes hard and
Stony and this is the part we call the
pit so think of peaches plums and
cherries they all have pits
so a pit is a hard covering around the
seed
the outermost part of the fruit called
the exocarp becomes a relatively thin
skin and the middle portion between the
skin and the pit becomes either fleshy
or fibrous
what about a coconut if you've ever seen
a fresh coconut you know that it comes
in a large fibrous husk so it's also a
droop
it's the fleshy fruit has a seed that is
not enclosed in a hard covering then
it's a berry
this includes almost all fruits with
more than one seed like tomatoes and
grapes
here's some real botany trivia too what
about an avocado
it seems to have a pit but the hard
thing in the middle is really the seed
not a hard covering around the seed so
an avocado is a berry
there are two special types of
berry-like fruits that I like to mention
solely for the fun of saying their names
in the grocery store the first is a
berry with a leathery rind and the
interior of the fruit is divided along
SEPTA into the carpals think of an
orange this is a special Berry called a
hesperidium now think of that same Berry
only with a hard rind and you have a
peepo which would be a watermelon or a
squash
our last fleshy simple fruit is a poem
and if you know French you'll already
guess that this is the fruit type for an
apple a poem is actually an accessory
fruit which means it's formed by Parts
other than the ovary
where is the ovary in an apple
it's in the very core and if you slice
the Apple just right you can see the
papery outer layer around the ovary
another accessory fruit is strawberry
which isn't a berry at all
why not
there aren't multiple seeds inside
surrounded by a fleshy fruit no in a
strawberry the seeds are on the outside
though they are not actually seeds they
are the fruits they are the Akins and
that's the part we enjoy or the part
that we enjoy is the swollen receptacle
or the base of the flower
so believe it or not there are so many
more terms that we did not go over but I
wanted to give you the basics as we move
forward into identification
remember that botany can feel like an
overwhelming language but all of these
words can be looked up in a book or on
the Internet with a lot of drawings and
photos
don't be overwhelmed by this material
but consider that you're well on your
way to speaking like a botanist
[Music]
foreign
[Music]